we begin this morning with diplomacy
being put to the test as the u.s and its
nato allies try to diffuse the tension
with russia over its possible invasion
of ukraine secretary of state anthony
blinken met with his russian counterpart
sergey lavrov in geneva switzerland
friday blinken told lavrov the u.s would
give russia written responses to
moscow's proposals next week there is
some hope that an invasion of ukraine is
delayed at least for now even though
both sides appear to be far apart on
larger potentially more consequential
issues russia has deployed tens of
thousands of troops along its border
with ukraine and its neighboring belarus
christina raffini is in geneva with the
latest christina good morning
good morning dana those meetings here
yesterday lasted about 90 minutes both
sides called them frank and productive
and although there were no major
breakthroughs they agreed to keep
talking but this comes as allies are
rushing weapons to ukraine in case
diplomacy fails
we
have
made clear
and done
a number of things
in support and defense of ukraine
that
that will continue
but speaking to reporters in geneva
friday secretary blinken made clear that
support will not include u.s ground
forces
ukraine is not not a member of nato it's
not covered by the article 5 commitment
following a high profile meeting with
his russian counterpart blinken said the
u.s is doing everything it can to help
ukraine in other ways
we think that's the best and most
effective way
to
convince russia not to
engage in further aggression against
ukraine overnight 200 thousand pounds of
lethal aid including ammunition arrived
in kiev
and the u.s has also given permission
for other nato allies to rush u.s made
weapons to ukraine's eastern front it's
good to see you as well then there's the
diplomatic front
what we expect is concrete answers to
our concrete proposals the bottom line
is this this is a critical moment
russia says it has no plans to invade
and its troop buildup is defensive but
the u.s has questioned how a country
with such a robust military could feel
threatened by its much smaller neighbor
is russia intimidated by ukraine why are
you afraid of over ukraine why do you
feel you need to protect yourself as we
are not afraid of anyone even not of the
us you know
secretary blinken said after consulting
with president biden he should be able
to have that written response to
moscow's proposal something russia has
been asking for by next week michelle
frank question christina glad you were
able to ask it
tomorrow on face the nation margaret
brennan speaks with secretary of state
anthony blinken